Assalamu
alayikum. Walaykum. Asalam. My name is
Joseph Siddiki and I work with my
brothers as a handyman for their real
estate business. I fix their rental
apartment on an hourly salary basis
income. They own approximately 300
apartment units that they repair on a
daily basis. Most of the apartments are
still on interest based investment that
have not been paid off yet. I don't own
any real estate property with them but I
am one of their workers. My question to
you sir is is my income halal according
to the Islamic law or should I find
another job?
Question is posed by Joseph Siddiki. He
is doing a freelancing work and he's
working for an estate company alias.
He's not fully employed and he's a
handyman who fixes plumbing or things of
the apartments and the apartments on
Herba. So is it permitted to work for a
company which owns uh apartments and
those apartments on Raa? Is it
permitted? As far as working in a
company, if the core activity of that
company is haram, you cannot work for
that company. You cannot work for Ariba
based bank. You cannot work for
alcoholic company because the core
activity is haram. You can't work for a
company which owns a gambling den and
the main activity is gambling den. But
for example, you're working for a
fivestar hotel. In the five-star hotel,
the sale of alcohol income is maybe 2%
3%. So can you work at the reception? No
problem. If you're working at a
reception of a five-star hotel is
permitted. But you cannot work as a
waiter in a restaurant which serves
alcohol because there you'll be forced
to serve alcohol. So that five-star
hotel may be having a restaurant which
serves alcohol. So you can work as a
manager or a receptionist of the hotel
where the main income is halal. Maybe a
small percentage is haram. So for the
owner of that hotel it is haram for him
to have a restaurant which has alcohol.
But for the worker for him to work as a
receptionist or a manager is no problem.
as long as he's not directly involved in
the alcohol restaurant. Similarly, you
as working for a handyman or as an
electrician or as a plumber for a real
estate company, the main activity of the
real estate companies, buying and
selling property, but it's taking on
reba. So, if you are working and just
repairing an apartment, is it haram or
halal? It's permitted. So tomorrow if
you are a mechanic and suppose a car
comes to you for for repairs you'll ask
the car owner okay is your car on ribba
or not if the car is on ribba you can
very well repair the car because the
main activity you cannot buy a car on
ribba but repairing a car which is on
ribba is permitted because it's not
directly involving in ribba so same way
you repairing a house or electrician or
a plumber or a handyman of a house which
is taken on ribba as permitted.
Similarly as you being a mechanic and a
car or a motorcycle or a bus comes which
is taken on ribba so you can repair it.
Your money is hala. Imagine there is a
doctor and a robber comes for his
treatment. A robber comes and pays
money. The doctor can take his fees. He
cannot take something which is robbed.
For example, if he's robbed an item and
he gives that item that's not permitted.
But if he's robbed and he's earned a lot
of money and if he pays his fees or a
person who owner of a bank he's sick and
he comes to a doctor a doctor treats him
he takes money the money is haram for
him but when he pays the doctor for the
doctor he's getting for his halal work.
So similarly if a mechanic of a car
takes money or you as a handyman or
electrician or a plumber take money for
your halal work it's permitted it's not
haram. Hope that answers the question.